me personally I'm a little bit creeped
out by the giving chase hi I'm Nick
Gillespie and today we're talking with
Aaron Greenwood she's the author of the
new young adult novels saved the enemy
thanks for talking with hi thanks for
having me
this novel is hilarious and it's funny I
think for all readers but libertarians
especially will like it because it's
about a girl whose parents whose mother
gets murdered her father goes missing
hilarious all right yeah I could barely
contain myself and it talked a little
bit about the libertarian dimension of
this novel what's going on oh sure well
the father is sort of a think-tank type
libertarian he he he is a big Iran
supporter he doesn't think that there
should be public transportation he's
very suspicious of public schools and
that sort of a thing and in theory he
would like to teach his daughters some
survival skills except he himself is
lacking all survival skills so it's a
very academic sort of a thing that he's
trying with and I mean this comes up in
all sorts of ways where the daughter is
but trying to please the father but also
is kind of like God a little suspicious
the book actually came to my attention I
was reading a story about you and and
and the novel in the National Journal
and you go on to slag talked about how
the the narrator in the books lags the
giving tree' here would you read what
the narrator how she explains the giving
tricks sure your dad probably read
eBooks like the giving tree when you
were a kid my dad did Read Me the giving
tree once calling it evil and that it
promotes the immoral destruction of the
self I was for he prefered Atlas
Shrugged which is basically about how
rich people shouldn't pay taxes it's
explained to me a lot over the course of
my 17 years that taxes are slavery are
you speaking through the character about
the giving tree' their i me personally
I'm a little bit creeped out by the
giving change what's what's wrong with
the giving tree' I mean it's a tree that
gives all to the little boy who keeps
coming back until he's an old man it
gives all I I'm uncomfortable with a
couple of aspects of the giving tree one
I I feel like it's sort of promotes some
gender roles that
I'm not so comfortable with it does seem
like a kind of maternal tree that's
giving up everything of herself for her
child although I I don't have children
myself but I understand that people
would give up any and let's be clear the
kid does it kay I mean he's not thankful
at all no makes me uncomfortable about
it is that the kid seems so even as he
matures into adulthood and then beyond
just you know adulthood he seems so
unaware of what it is that she has given
up for him I always I see it as kind of
the prequel to the Harry Chapin song
cat's in the cradle but now what about
Atlas Shrugged do you I mean so are you
more in line with Atlas Shrugged I
wouldn't say that I'm fully in line with
that list reg2 either I feel like I feel
like both stories probably have their
you know have their they're good
messages and they're bad messages in
there so it's safe to say that save the
enemy takes place between you know the
bloody crossroads that is the giving
tree and Atlas Shrugged you know you've
just summed up the book in the best
possible way where does this humor come
from in your life uh well I I it's a
lucky thing I happen to be married to a
libertarian but I've also spent some
time in the libertarian think-tank world
myself when I was new in DC and I was I
was I used to be a lawyer and I moved to
DC and I decided I didn't want to be a
lawyer anymore I was working as a writer
and one of the gigs that I got was
working at a free-market think-tank um
and that's actually how I met my husband
the libertarian um right well we'll get
to him well unmask him but how do you
perceive libertarians generally
obviously they're good you know they're
good for humor but what's the essence of
libertarianism so I think libertarians
are great I love their analytical
integrity is sort of willing to take an
idea and see it through all the way to
the end and explore its natural
conclusion and not sort of cut off an
idea at the point at which other people
might get uncomfortable and decided that
it's time to abandon ship and that shows
up in the book at one point the it
appears as if that murdered mother is
come
cating via some kind of supernatural
ability to a kind of Asperger's or
autistic brother of the of the narrator
the main character and the main
character is saying you know I know that
I can't believe in metaphysical you know
or supernatural beings but I kind of
want to yeah I mean it's rich in human
pathos I think it's humor yeah well I
mean this is really this is sort of
aside from having to actually find her
father who's been kidnapped this is sort
of her main struggle is trying to figure
out is she more like her dad and you
know in that she prizes rationality
above everything else or is she more
like her mom in which you know in the
sense that she's sort of willing to
follow impulses and inclinations and the
things that she wants to believe rather
than the things that logic would dictate
now you are married to Ray Lehmann who
works at a group called R Street and how
did he help you I mean in your
acknowledgement you say he helped kind
of work through some of the humor yeah
the book yeah I you know frequently a
situation would arise in the book and I
would say huh I wonder what the father
would do in this situation what would
the brothers say right here and I would
turn to him and say hey ray if you were
you know let's let's say you were doing
X Y Z thing you know what would you say
and he would give me a little snippet of
dialogue or a subject that is really
something I couldn't have come up with
on my own
well now you right I mean you're a
journalist at the huffington post and
you have but you have described your
politics as a kind of namby-pamby
liberal libertarian liberal latter okay
so kind that everybody hates what what
kinds of things do you cover I mean
while you cover quirky DC for the
Huffington Post so if you were to
covering kinky DC there'd be a lot to
cover
quirky maybe not so much but what what
what's interesting about the city for
your Huffington Post stuff uh you know
I've actually found a lot of things that
are interesting here and one of my
favorite stories that I covered was
about Hank the cat who was a cat in
Virginia who was running for a US Senate
seat covered that very closely and I
think that cat may have upholds the
liberty
that in that race I think you yeah yeah
I mean I've written about I I I tend to
write a lot about animals and very
interested in animals and we have a lot
of animal things going on around here
and I've written about you know if dogs
should be granted some form of
personhood how do you feel about that as
a liberal Terrier
as a little time I I'm not sure that my
liberated dogs have a guaranteed safety
net I think they say government well I
think some minimal safety net for all
sentient beings and dogs can Assad Nancy
Michael Vick's auntie and Michael Vick
yeah that's right I wrote about on an
MMA fighter who's been challenging
Michael Vick to get in the ring he says
you know the shedding of blood is the
only way that the animal people will
will sort of let him let him get on with
his life well save the enemy is out now
it's from Aaron Greenwood thank you so
much for talking to Reason TV today good
luck at The Huffington Post them with
the book for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you